She Hulk what do I think about She-Hulk
it was campy it was funny it was uh it
was well acted I think it was well made
I thought the special effects and
everything was great they didn't cheat
US on that they gave us everything we
wanted on that and I thought it was like
oh well this is cool like I like the
Hulk Universe like other than like
worrying about Avengers and all that
stuff I like seeing like this is the
Hulk being the Hulk and like this is
like you know Hulk stuff you know so
then she's like an attorney so it's
going to be like sort of like an
episodic you know it's like it's a it's
an attorney show it's a fun attorney
show uh it she just though happens to be
the Hulk did I buy how she became the
Hulk no I thought it was like a lazy
cheesy way for her to be to become the
Hulk but I'm still all in I liked it
five woo-woos for She-Hulk I can't wait
I'm gonna watch the whole season I'm in
they got me hooked like I say it was a
campy cheesy mess in terms of like you
know what I mean like it's like one of
those guilty pleasures oh do you watch
She-Hulk you know I love old school
sitcoms shows it reminds me of like it
reminds me of like Moonlighting with
Bruce Willis I don't know if you guys
you old people remember that just a fun
detective show I feel like this is gonna
be like that a fun lawyer show with the
Hulk involved